our initial
shutdown was to prevent the overflow
of our hospitals and to allow us to meet
the demands caused by this global
pandemic
including the ventilators and a
permanent shutdown was
really never an option in terms of what
we're doing right now
this would be completely unsustainable
produce
debilitating economic fallback and lead
to catastrophic public health
consequences there are consequences to
shutdowns
that was president of course at his
coronavirus press briefing today fox
news medical correspondent mark segal is
on his way to washington tonight we're
sending him to the white house he's
going to interview the president
about what the administration is doing
to contain the wuhan coronavirus part 1
airs here at 8 pm eastern
part 2 on shannon's show at 11.
but first a new round of mandatory
shutdowns is pitting small business
owners
against their state governments the ones
they pay for
ian smith for example is the owner of
the attila's gym in belmar new jersey
we spoke to him earlier this year he
tried to open
his gym in defiance of a state shutdown
order
now he's taking extraordinary measures
to stay open he's even removed his front
door to prevent the state from keeping
the door closed too bad he's not an
abortion clinic or a liquor store he
would have no problem
at all ian smith joins us tonight ian
thanks so much for coming on
so thanks for having me state is trying
to shut you down
is there first to the science is there
evidence that your
gym has been a vector for a hotbed of
the spread of chronovirus
we have record of every single person
who has stepped foot
um and the total number of check-ins
well exceeding the thousands
uh not a single case has been reported
so far uh and we've kept detailed record
of that
uh all the way through okay so
i mean this literally you would have
been better off
joining a mob of rioters torching other
people's businesses
then you are responsibly following the
science and trying to keep belmar new
jersey healthy
why are you being hounded by the state
do you think
um i think that we are being haunted by
the state because
we are pushing back against a very very
clear political agenda at this point
and we've become a thorn in the side for
governor murphy
and my partner and i are not willing to
back down we're not going to have our
lives destroyed over a political agenda
that has nothing to do with us
so what is the governor threatening to
do to your gym
uh the police force was initially
weaponized against us with citation
after citation after citation uh then it
was the health department
uh we were shut down without anybody
ever stepping foot inside of our our
building
and then it's the court system the court
system enforced the shutdown
um and locked our doors on us and then
we finally got them removed and
we had workouts outside for a couple
weeks and the it was
it was absurd we were dragging half of
the gym outside close to 30 000 pounds
worth of equipment every single day
and on july 4th we resumed and now the
courts are being weaponized against us
again we were held in contempt of court
um and we we narrowly escaped that last
night
so again it's just a weaponization of
these public
organizations and offices that are meant
to serve and protect the people
and they're clearly being used to punish
us
yeah and a certain kind of people i mean
again if you're running a liquor store
selling state lotto tickets running an
abortion clinic you would have no
problem at all you
run a gym one of the healthiest
businesses by definition
this country has do you think it's odd
that they're
persecuting you i think it points to the
uh very clear fact that this is not
about public health
um first of all public health is not a
one-dimensional issue
public health does not start and finish
with covet there are many
other things that we have to consider
mental health being one of them
um you know and all these other things
and everything that seems to be
unhealthy for you
or at least sort of average
is allowed but you can't go work out the
studies
all around the world coming out of
norway we have studies in the united
states
all the science points to the fact that
if you allow people to work out
regularly that you have lower infection
rates
and the government has provided no data
to
show that gyms are of any danger to
anybody
and we've provided data over and over
again the ihrsa
collected a bunch of studies and data
and wrote a letter to every single
governor so they all have this
information
and they still seem to point the finger
and point the blame at us
but again with with nothing but
conclusionary statements with nothing to
back them up
it's almost like they're trying to
weaken and degrade the populations
they'll be easier to control i mean you
know who knows
i'm connecting the dots a little bit ian
great to see you good luck
thank you very much tucker